the key fallacy that is behind all of
this is the thought that people have in
their minds that if they just do a great
job every single day this is the only
thing that they do then they will get
noted they will get promoted they will
have a successful career and this is a
mindset that people adopt from leaving
high school maybe even from going to
University well of course there's a link
between your immediate performance the
time you put in to study and then the
results this link is much more
established but this is a fallacy after
on everyone knows there's a trust to
just spend a couple of years in
corporate this is a fallacy this is not
how it works